branle bas de combat au sein de
l'établissement public foncier des
yvelines il s'estime menacé la semaine
dernière un amendement a été présenté à
l'assemblée nationale avec en premier
alinéa ce qui sonne comme une douche
froide il ne peut exister qu'un seul
établissement foncier de l'état par
région or en ile de france il existe un
établissement régional et des antennes
départementales dont une dans les
yvelines pour le président conseiller
général fermer cet établissement dans le
rôle est de conseiller voire de
cautionner les communes dans la
réalisation de logements c'est tout
simplement un frein à la politique de
construction depuis 2006 120 conventions
ont été signées dans le département et
cela représente en termes de
potentialités de logements parfaitement
identifiés et répertoriés sur ces
conventions une potentialité de 35 mille
logements la grosse particularité de
l'établissement public foncier des
yvelines c'est de travailler avec toutes
les collectivités
même sur des petits projets à peu près
20% pas plus des dossiers que nous
traitons sont du niveau de ceux qui sont
traitées au niveau de l'agencé tels que
80 qui ne serait pas n'aurait jamais vu
le jour pour les conseillers généraux
socialistes cette inquiétude n'a pas
lieu d'être l'efs qui est un outil qui a
fait ses preuves mais ce débat se doit
de poser une autre question
que ça
en fait une pose question et que très
vite on se pose plutôt la vraie
problématique est ce qu'il vaut ne pas
voir une bonne coordination entre le
niveau départemental au niveau régional
en un mot cela
une tempête dans un verre d'eau les
salariés de l'établissement public
foncier des yvelines en seront plus le 4
octobre lors de la réunion de la
commission mixte paritaire
si la fermeture devait intervenir cela
se ferait dans les 18 mois